pardon monsieur attention à part 2 est
là et bien venez avec moi parce qu'ici
on va découvrir alençon une nouvelle
maison d'édition qui s'appelle le petit
oiseau est ce qu'il va sortir je ne sais
pas allô oui c'est là où ça bouge on
peut venir voir le petit oiseau c'est
bien ça vient de sortir et nous on va
rentrer ça me fait plaisir de vous
retrouver parce que c'est une nouvelle
maison d'édition
tout à fait on arrive comme ça à
l'improviste un mais c'est un petit peu
le principe de l'eau ça bouge vous êtes
de en place du piquant sur alençon un an
ouais si l'on n'est entreprise existe
depuis maintenant plus de dix ans en
revanche là pour le petit oiseau c'est
votre premier livre
tout à fait je vais le chercher j'habite
une ville fantôme et qui l'auteur donc
thibaut derien qui est là qui avec nous
qu'on connaît par la musique puisqu'il a
déjà sorti deux albums vous avez dit
tout à l'heure vous avez fait là la
troisième partie de la deuxième partie
de deux des marques
quant au zénith au zénith il ya dix ans
en 2005 et vous continuez à faire de la
musique ou maintenant j'ai arrêté la
musique qu'il ya cinq ans
attendez
piment fait couler beaucoup trop dans
quoi parce que j'écrivais plus de
chansons tableaux des bus way puis
j'avais envie de passer à autre chose en
fait je suis revenue à la première
passion la photographie
et donc voilà ce livre j'habite une
ville fantôme
vous êtes dans un esprit non pas de
nostalgie mais de mémoire peut être plus
tôt ouais ya plusieurs grilles de
lecture moi j'ai commencé à les prendre
en photo justement pendant mes tournées
j'ai fait ces photos de 2005 à 2015
j'étais d'abord freq frappé par le côté
graphique de ces vieilles anciennes et
puis par le côté nous venge pas
m'empêcher d'imaginer toutes ses vies
passées derrière ces ses volets fermés
pour moi personnellement il ya un petit
peu de nostalgie passe comme julia main
je me souviens à l'acheter mais bon bec
la petite boulangerie du coin comme ça
oui on serre les boulangeries
retrouverez mais le petit commerce ou le
petit disque et on acheter les vinyles
par exemple voilà et sinon le côté
graphique parce que comme je suis
graphiste j'aime aussi beaucoup l'aspect
graphique 2d photographie thibault qui
sont très quelques dans un format carré
vous êtes un exemple auto coeur puisque
finalement parce que créer une maison
d'édition
en ce moment c'est quand même du courage
ma merci j'avais une ville fantôme par
thibaut derien aux éditions petit oiseau
déjà disponible en librairie là où ça
bouge chez france 3
mamma mia
en pleine résidence le groupe big
sisters dont nous allons faire le
portrait dans quelques instants
ils viennent de sortir leur tout premier
ep
dassault
on est un groupe de rock aux accents ce
toner mais on est plus axé sur sur le
groupe en fait sur la petite vague des
pôles le petit claquement de doigts
c'est vraiment sûr sur l'énergie
organique peut dégager un groupe de rock
plein de plans de feeling en fait
on a vraiment le droit de de partir sur
les inspirations comme le jazz mais
vraiment là c'est libre c'est comme ça
qu'on va partir sur les créations
musicales convoi composé c'est vraiment
chacun apporte sa patte
dans un groupe de musique et de rock en
particulier il faut il faut que la
section rythmique elle assure donc nous
deux on est quand même faut qu'on soit
carré mais on a on a une approche un peu
théâtral de la scène du coup on est
c'est pas grave s'il ya quelque chose
qui passe à côté
les meilleurs
pour souvent la question pourquoi
anglais pourquoi pas français parce que
ça va mieux j'imagine avec cette musique
l'anglais surtout parce que je suis
anglaise alors je n'arrive vraiment pas
à écrire en français ça me vient pas
naturellement et j'arrive que vraiment à
m'expliquer exprimé en euros
on estime qu'un concert c'est avant tout
un spectacle et que ça mérite une mise
en scène ça mérite une création lumière
ça mérite un vrai travail que ce soit au
niveau costumes accessoires et c'est
vraiment un show complet big sister
c'était vraiment l'occasion de faire ça
parce que voilà c'est un univers qui est
très particulier ils ont déjà une
identité visuelle qui est assez
approfondies et c'est un style comme
cohn bendit et c'est vachement axée sur
le groove et il ya possibilité de faire
énormément de choses autour de ça